[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages as they arrive time then
to see what's making the headlines with
the ft's political journalist jasmine
cameron shileshi and the telegraph's
assistant comment editor olivia utley
with us from now until just before
midnight and uh welcome to both of you
on what is once again another very busy
day so to the front pages then the
telegraph says boris johnson is under
pressure to release the full version of
sue gray's report into parties at downey
street during lockdown
the metro reacts to the announcement of
a police investigation into those
gatherings declaring you've had your
parties now here is the bill
here's the eyes big splash pm in peril
as police called in
the guardian also says mr johnson's
position is
perilous while the financial times
describes the prime minister as gearing
up for a fight for survival
the times writes johnson could face a
police interview over the party's
allegations
the sun making a joke of it picturing a
police officer marching into number 10
and the star reports that investigators
have been sent pictures of the pm at
number 10 with wine bottles close by its
headline plonker
well the daily express remarks the
public want a line drawn under partygate
2.
well just a quick reminder by scanning
the qr code that you will see on screen
during the program you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's newspapers
while you watch us so let's bring in our
guests this evening we're joined tonight
by jasmine cameron shileshi and olivia
artley i'm clearly at downing street for
a very important reason uh jasmine what
an extraordinary day once again for the
prime minister
yeah it's been a very very intense day
and i think there is a sense that
definitely heading into tomorrow and the
rest of the week things aren't actually
going to calm down this morning we heard
um from the met that they were launching
the investigation into some of the um
allegations of law breaking in downing
street and across whitehall and the pm
said that he welcomed the report and he
wanted to draw a line under it and in
some ways um it is in the government's
advantage to essentially get this over
and done with
this has been hanging over the
government for weeks now we've seen a
drip drip drip of new allegations and
new stories coming in
but it's not a great look for the pm to
have the police investigating his
officials and investigating his conduct
throughout the pandemic i think this is
a story that really resonates with the
public because the pandemic was
something that forced the government to
make policies that impacted everyone
everyone had a birthday of the pandemic
everyone has a story everyone made
sacrifices and this lingering idea that
those making the rules weren't actually
following them and now the police have
to get involved it's not it's really not
looking great for the pm
yes and if we look at your paper olivia
it's not every day you see dame cressida
on the front page there while talking
about a possible police interview with
the prime minister but your headline is
the pressure on johnson to release the
full gray report what is the distinction
there what might be published instead of
the full report well this morning
the telegraph front page really gives
quite a good indication of how the
events of the day have played out and it
has been a very dramatic day this
morning we heard that there was going to
be this police investigation and for a
while it looked as though that police
investigation might delay the
publication of the grey report which
sort of paradoxically might actually be
quite good for the prime minister um
because the grey report is what what
he's sort of dreading and the longer the
longer that's held off for the police
investigation would take a while uh
there's always the chance that you know
russia invades ukraine the world's got
their eye somewhere else and the whole
thing fizzles out um and then yesterday
there were sort of indications that that
the prime minister might not actually
publish the report in full he might just
sort of talk about the findings in the
report and it was made clear that it was
at the prime minister's discretion how
much of the report he was going to
publish but as the front page of the
telegraph makes clear all of that sort
of changed over the course of the day
sugree and the police have now both made
clear that there's no legal impediment
or no impediment in either of their eyes
to the sugar report being published
concurrently with the police
investigation and it now looks like that
report actually might be published
tomorrow um and then you've got sue gray
quoted there in in that report um
in the report in the telegraph uh saying
that saying that you know she would like
the report to be published in full
there's now just a lot of pressure on
the prime minister to publish the whole
report no reactions no not just the
findings not just a summary but the
whole report in full um while the police
investigation is happening too so
if we're talking about dramatic crunches
it's about as dramatic as you can
possibly get
absolutely and that reflected uh in the
financial times as well jasmine johnson
gears up for a fight for survival and
many of the newspapers saying that
really this critically is the most
serious 48 hours in his premiership so
far
yeah i think that's fair and i think
generally mps on the back benches are
really sort of falling into tea camps so
there are those who would argue that
actually we should wait until the grey
report is published we should wait until
the met have finished their enquiries
and then they'll make a judgment as to
whether actually letters need to be
submitted or whether a line can be drawn
under the whole affair and then there
are those who actually argue well we've
seen enough we've heard enough and
actually johnson's becoming a liability
their argument is that the johnson who
was elected in 2019 who managed to win
over those red hall voters and red wall
seats who managed to win that huge
majority they're arguable actually
that's not what johnson we're seeing now
and i think especially some mps in and
seats for there are small majorities and
where they believe that labour voters
effectively lent their vote to
the conservative mps there's a real
questioning of johnson's leadership and
so i think um you know we're really
seeing
this sort of
concern on the back benches as to
whether johnson is the right person to
be leading them into the this next stage
and i think in some ways johnson's
slightly lucky and that even though
there's all this concern on the back
benches there isn't actually a natural
successor there's talk of rishi sunak
and liz trust but then the question is
um does the next conservative leader
want to be sort of coming in at a point
of rising tax and at a point where we've
got the local elections around the
corner
absolutely yes the cost of living crisis
the may elections that the list goes on
for whoever is in charge if we look at
the eye as well uh peril to olivia is
the word they use and they say that
downey street aides fear an avalanche of
no-confidence uh letters uh from
backbenchers presumably should sue gray
find uh that the actions here in downey
street and elsewhere across whitehall
were wanting um but of course because
it's already gone to the police in a
sense do we already know the verdict
uh
i think it's i think it's sort of easy
to underplay the importance of the sue
grey report actually given the police
investigation but i do think it's
incredibly important because the the the
mps who are sort of
not staunch boris allies but haven't yet
sent in their letters of no confidence i
think they're probably sort of hoping
for a ladder to climb down they're
hoping that there'll be something in the
gray report that they can cling on to
that allows them to say
look we can draw a line under this it's
it's bad but but we can move on and you
know we don't need a change of leader
now that they're looking for something
that allows them to back boris because
as jasmine says there is no obvious
replacement but if the sue grey report
is very very damning in its language and
because the prime minister has built it
up to such a degree you know we've all
been talking about this for so many days
and weeks all of wester is so ready for
this su grey report and if it comes out
as totally damning then then those mps
have got sort of nothing left to hold on
to and their constituents are really
going to be
pushing them to send in those letters of
no confidence so i think you know
although
one could say that the police
investigation is sort of taking the wind
out of su grey's sails i think they'll
be sort of slightly to misunderstand
where where tory mps are sitting this
evening
yes the uh the guardian two talks about
peril and uh olivia's right isn't she uh
jasmine the pm and uh you know many of
the cabinet who've been questioned have
been hiding behind su gray like the
shield of captain america or in the case
of boris johnson possibly
saint george uh did if he had a shield
but what does he hide behind once this
is over i mean you know how do you see
this playing out
yeah i mean it's it's so uncertain at
the moment um and there have been so
many points over the past few days we
sort of thought letters were going to go
in and then it sort of all died down i
think what is clear is that there is a
sense of weariness not just among the
cabinet but benches as well that this
has gone on for such a long time we
heard in the comments today that there
are mp saying there's a cost of living
crisis there's issues with ukraine
there's a frustration that mps are
having to talk about this and that
instead of talking about policy
announcements or sort of trying to work
through the manifesto actually this is
sort of paralyzed government and so
there is a massive frustration around
that and i i think
you know it's not sure it's not clear
how this will play out but i do think
people want to draw a line under this
effectively
and the sun a bit of fun with this hello
you know quite a nice front page from
them it makes the point about the the
police inquiry in an accessible way but
there has been defense today you know
advisors and ministers uh former people
who've worked with uh with with people
here suggesting that actually this is a
unique building it's like a submarine
it's like a tardis
and for boris johnson of course it's his
home and his office all of these
distinguishing features about downing
street will any of those do you think be
used in defense when we finally get sue
grey's report
i don't think those defenses sort of
play particularly well with the public
um you know this idea that the kind of
downing street drinking culture seems
isn't quite the sort of defense that mps
think it is i don't think you know that
that well we're all just drinking at
work that's not the way most people work
and also if you were you know builder
had been working very hard on the
building site all day in may 2020 went
to have a drink and with your colleagues
on a bench then you would have been sent
home by the police so
i don't really think that stands um
there are there are some defenses that
that there's some
that aids and and boris johnson
supporters can sort of pull out that i
think you know i think talking about
what boris johnson has done well in the
past six months or so um
would be could be sort of beneficial for
them but i think that's probably a
stronger defense to talk about how how
britain is you know most anti-rich
antibody rich country uh in the world um
how we're leading the country out of the
pandemic those are all big boris johnson
ticks by his name um he's doing very
well on ukraine obviously better than
most of the eu uh so so i think those
are the sort of defenses that that boris
johnson allies should be going with
rather than this thing that you know the
rules didn't really apply to the prime
minister because it's crown property or
or they like drinking at their desks and
so work is kind of a party i don't
really think that sits very well with
the public
well and how much he can throw forward
to global events as well namely ukraine
and that is where we turn our attention
to next how might britain get involved
in the conflict in ukraine that in just
a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview live from downey street
tonight big issues obviously on the
prime minister's plate we're joined once
again by jasmine cameron shileshi and
olivia utley welcome back to both of you
and of course he chose today to make a
statement in the house of commons about
ukraine which is extremely serious
so olivia let's look at the times front
page and about the potential
contribution that the uk could make to
nato's effort
yeah and to start it it was a very
statement-like speech from boris johnson
actually and it was very interesting to
see that the way the tone in the house
of commons changed we had all these sort
of particular points going as you'd
expect about daniel street and cakes and
everything and then you got sort of a
very kind of honest earnest uh
commendation for what the government's
doing in ukraine from both sides of the
house and it's quite powerful speech
from the prime minister and what it
seems like britain is now planning to do
is we're readying troops to send to
hungary to bolster defenses there um and
it
it looks like the west is considering
imposing very very uh harsh sanctions on
russia which would involve cutting
russia off from the world's payment
system which would basically
stop russia having access to uk back to
western banks um overnight uh and and
you know cutting russia off completely
economically um so it does seem like
western leaders are kind of pulling
together now and it does seem like
britain is actually leading the charger
and the big issue of course is gas for
europe uh germany obviously is set great
stall by nordstrom to this gas pipeline
which is at obeyance at the moment has
not been fully sanctioned and the
guardian suggesting that actually there
might be other means of circumventing
the import of russian gas as a as a
means of protecting europe
yeah so i think i mean there's been
concern over what's happening in ukraine
for several weeks now and i think the
big question was how far are western
allies and nato prepared to go to
effectively um you know prevent russia
from expanding and i think there's a lot
of fear at um
what this means for sort of oil and gas
supplies we know that um russia is sort
of a big player in that field and so the
us is naturally trying to reassure its
european allies that actually regardless
of what happens there are there are
alternatives
and you know there is support available
and i think just touching on olivia's
point i think we saw a very sort of
confident um johnson in the house of
commons talking about ukraine there is a
sense that actually the uk is trying to
lead the charge on this and i think on
one hand that's quite helpful
politically for johnson because he can
point to ukraine and say look um we've
got bigger issues at hand here we
shouldn't be talking about birthday
cakes and parties look at what's
happening around the corner actually
we've got potentially a big crisis on
our hands and i think for those johnson
allies in the house of commons they can
also point to what's happening and say
well is now the time for a change of
leader or a leadership contest when
actually we should stick with johnson
and
hope that actually
he's the best person to lead us through
not just domestic but potentially
international crisis
yes and indeed on social media some
suggesting what the pm needs is a
falklands moment which is a you know a
very extreme bit of red meat to throw is
it not um for the moment both of you
thank you both very much indeed live
from downey street as we still await uh
that a report from sue gray so olivia
and jasmine thank you both very much and